-Hello, everyone, and welcome
back to the attic crawl space.
On Monday,
we answered a question
many viewers had been
wondering about --
what's behind that tiny,
little door back there
when my kids escaped at
the end of "Closer Look."
Now, a lot of people online
have said they were adorable
and too cute for words,
and I assure you,
they are...
in nine-second chunks.
Also, some of you might be
looking at me right now,
wondering, does Seth know
he's already worn that shirt?
And yeah, I know.
I promise you, I know.
And I do wish I had
a deeper roster of shirts,
but in my defense,
no one warned me
multiple times about
the possibility of a pandemic
because I'm not the president.
That's a segue.
And now, even after ignoring
those warnings,
the president is pushing to
prematurely reopen the economy,
threatening to repeat
the mistakes he made
at the start of this crisis.
For more of this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
When Donald Trump
was elected in 2016,
this was exactly the kind
of nightmare scenario
everyone was afraid of --
What would happen
in a global crisis
if the most powerful
man in the world
was a racist game show host
who failed at virtually
everything in his life,
except for pretending to be
a successful businessman on TV?
and he is not even good
at pretending.
Look at him pretending
to be president.
He just stares directly
into the camera,
and he can't even be bothered
to, at least, put some
fake documents on his desk.
You can almost
hear the dial tone
blasting out of the phone.
He looks like a tourist
taking a photo on the set
of "Deep Impact."
[ As Donald Trump ] "Wow.
Is this the phone
Morgan Freeman used?
You know, everyone freaked out
about the asteroid
in that movie,
but it ended up being no worse
than the common everyday flu."
[ Normal voice ] The point is,
this is the crisis
everyone feared.
In fact,
before Trump took office,
President Obama's outgoing team
tried to prepare
Trump's incoming team
for this exact scenario.
a scenario experts
had warned about for years.
-Days before
Donald Trump took office,
some
of President Obama's advisors
walked the incoming
president's team
through a hypothetical scenario
remarkably like the one
we are living through now.
It was a briefing on what would
happen
if a quick spreading virus
were to race through
London and Seoul,
and in that scenario,
they presented governments
imposing travel bans.
There were shortages at
hospitals across the country,
and today,
roughly two-thirds of those
Trump administration officials
who participated
in that simulation
are no longer in government.
-That's right.
Most of the Trump officials
who worked for him back then
aren't even there anymore.
They're either in jail,
on Fox News,
or in the bargain bin
at a Barnes & Noble.
"Hi, excuse me.
This Sean Spicer book
only has blank pages."
"Huh, look at that.
I guess you're the first person
to ever open one."
This White House has
more staff turnover
than a Six Flags
over summer break.
They made the Six Flags mascot
commerce secretary.
What Obama's team
should have done is
run a simulation
for what would happen
when a sociopath President
dismisses repeated warnings
from intelligence officials
and public health experts
that a pandemic is coming.
and fires anyone
who's done any planning for it.
Okay. So, the first thing
you do in that case is,
you call up Netflix,
and you get them to release
an emergency bonus episode
of "Tiger King" ASAP.
You know, think of it as a --
I don't know --
a where-are-they-now situation.
You know, maybe,
someone got new teeth.
And, again, you know, obviously,
let's pray it never
comes to this.
In fact, as we've now learned,
one former Trump official,
homeland security adviser
Tom Bossert was a part
of a group of people trying
to warn the government
in a series of exchanges
called the "Red Dawn" e-mails.
The e-mails were nicknamed
after the 1984
Patrick Swayze movie,
but, if you're going
to pick a Swayze movie,
I feel like "Ghost" would
have been a better choice,
since the government's response
is clearly being lead by one.
I mean, yikes.
[ Chuckles ] Look at him.
Jared Kushner looks like
he just appeared out of nowhere
after someone read
an Edgar Allen Poe story
into a cracked mirror...
and then demanded
you pay for the mirror.
It's weird that
the public health response
is being led by a guy
who looks like he would sneak
into your hospital room
and pinch your IV line closed
until you told him
where the microfilm was.
"It's a simple question."
So, in those "Red Dawn" e-mails,
we found out
that Bossert and others
had expressed concerns
about Trump's slow
and incoherent response,
like for example,
when trump announced
a hasty and confusing
European travel ban
that led to jam-packed airports
in cities like Chicago
after there were
already documented cases
of community spreading
here in the U.S.,
Bossert wrote,
"Can anyone justify
the European travel
restrictions,
scientifically?
Seriously, is there any benefit?
I don't see it,
but I'm hoping there's
something I don't know."
That's how we all feel,
but it's never the case.
With Trump, things are always
exactly as they seem.
For example, we see him using
every muscle in his face
to squint at the teleprompter
like he is staring
at a "Magic Eye" poster
and say, "I think
the president can't see,
but I'm hoping there's
something I don't know."
And then, you tune in
to his unhinged
Rose Garden press conference
Tuesday night,
in which he announced,
in the middle of
a global pandemic,
that he was pulling funding
from World Health Organization,
and you see this.
-I instructed my team to use
the Defense Protection Act.
and the Defense Production Act
was used very powerfully.
All the aid that we send
will be...discussed...
at very, very powerful letl--
letters.
We see light.
We're starting to see it
more than ever before.
We've held our...
rate, the numbers,
everything we've done.
We've been very, very...
strong on it
and very powerful on it.
-He sounds like
a guy on a date
getting lines
through an earpiece
and the feed just cut out.
[ As Donald Trump ] The light
in your eyes is so...
It's so...
Well, it is lighty.
I mean, they're your eyes.
You know.
[ Normal voice ] Also,
I like when his brain melts,
his go to-words
are strong and powerful.
it's like I'm listening
to a focus group
on advertising
for pickup trucks.
"Okay, folks.
What are some words
that might make you want
to buy a Ford F-150?"
[ As Donald Trump ] "Strong!
Uh, powerful!
Ve-- very powerful!
That would be
another word for me.
If you want
to put that down for me."
[ Normal voice ] And by the way,
that's the guy news networks
have decided to air unfiltered
during a national emergency,
the guy who he can't even
read his own script.
If that's the content you want,
cable networks,
just take a live feed of
my grandpa at his next eye exam.
And by the way,
it doesn't make it better
when you give it
a negative chyron,
like CNN did on Monday, with,
"Angry Trump turns briefing
into propaganda session."
You know what else turned that
into a propaganda session?
Pointing your camera at it.
Before you showed up,
it was just,
"Crazy lawn man does his thing."
You can't air
a propaganda session
and criticize it.
It's like if MTV had
aired "Jersey Shore"
with the disclaimer,
"Change the channel.
This show sucks."
And that is what it was,
a propaganda session.
In fact, the White House edited
together a campaign-style
video highlighting
Trump's various statements
about the crisis,
and Trump actually had
people inside your government,
paid with your tax dollars,
make that video.
-I've never seen a video
like that played in this room.
It looks a bit
like a campaign ad.
Who produced that video for you?
-That was done
by a group in the office.
-Yeah, this was done
by Dan and a group of people.
-Oh! Oh, it was done by Dan
and a group of people.
First of all, it's funny
that it was only Dan
who got named,
and everyone else who was
complicit in this bull[bleep]
got lumped in
to a group of people.
Trump knows how
to accidently shame someone
by giving them credit
for something terrible.
[ As Donald Trump ] "Dan?
Dan, you want to come over here
and talk
about the propaganda video
you made with taxpayer dollars?
You shaking your head no, Dan?
Dan?
Dan, do you want
to come up here?
Dan, show everyone your face
and take credit
for this thing you did.
Dan? No? Fauci?
How about you, Fauci?
You want to say
a few words about Dan?
Made you touch
your face again, Fauci.
This guy.
Love you, Fauc."
[ Normal voice ] Particularly,
Trump keeps touting his ban
on travel from China.
but, according to experts,
the ban only served
to buy the White House time
to ramp up testing
and hospital capacity
and start community
mitigation efforts,
time they wasted,
and when he was asked
to explain what he did
with all that time in February,
Trump decided to get in
to a fight with the reporter,
Paula Reid of CBS,
who asked the question.
-Thousands of lives by --
-The argument is that you
bought yourself some time.
You didn't use it
to prepare hospitals.
to ramp up testing.
-You're so -- You're so --
You're so disgraceful.
It is so disgraceful
the way you say that.
Let me just -- Listen.
I just went over it.
Nobody thought we should do it,
and when I did it --
But what did you do
with the time that you bought?
-You know what we did?
-The month of February?
That was a gap.
-You know what we did?
What do you do --
-The entire month of February.
-What do you do
when you have no case
in the whole United States --
-You had cases in February.
-Excuse me, you reported it.
Zero cases, zero deaths
on January 17th.
-In January.
February, the entire --
-Janua-- I said in January.
-Your video has a complete gap.
-On January 3rd.
-What did the administration
do in February with the time
that your travel ban bought you?
-A lot.
-What?
-A lot, and in fact,
we'll give you a list.
-[ As Donald Trump ] "Dan?
Dan, can you get us
that list you made
of everything
we did in February?
You're shaking
your head no, Dan,
but I know you have a list
of everything done in February
that this lady
is asking me about.
The February list, Dan!
It will be between
the January list
and then the March list.
Dan?
Don't make me tell everyone
your last name, Dan.
It's Scavino."
[ Normal voice ] Also, thank you
for reminding Trump to his face
that there are real-world
consequences here.
for the thousands who have
died and their loved ones,
the nearly 20 million
who have lost their jobs,
the millions who have
lost health insurance,
the courageous health
care professionals
putting themselves in danger
on the front line.
and all of the essential workers
delivering mail and packages
and working grocery stores
and on public transit
and doing the hard,
dangerous work
while the rest of us surf
to the bottom of Netflix,
looking for another trashy
reality show to watch.
"Honey, have we watched
'[Bleep] Island' yet?"
Oh, right.
Yeah, we did.
Oh, wait! Honey,
there's a new bonus episode.
Aw, they got divorced, honey.
Yeah.
Yeah, I guess once the couples
got back from the main land,
they realized the connections
they made on [bleep] island
weren't as enduring as
they've been led to believe.
I guess romance is dead, honey."
And now Trump is
once again rushing
to prematurely
reopen the economy,
even though
public health experts
have nearly unanimously warned
that such move could lead
to a second wave
of the outbreak.
Dr. Fauci warned
about this on Sunday.
Bill Gates said,
we won't go back to normal
until there's a vaccine.
Dr. Ezekiel Emanuel said
concerts, conferences,
and sporting events likely
won't return until fall 2021
at the earliest.
and a Harvard study
said yesterday,
some social distancing measures
may be needed until 2022.
So, yeah, I'm gonna
have to rewatch
every episode of
"[Bleep] Island"
with the director's
commentary on it.
"You know, we were originally
going to do it on Isthmus,
but, we thought,
[bleep] isthmus was
too hard to say,
so we went with an island."
And yet, our split-
personality President
has, in a matter of days,
gone back and forth
between claiming he has
unquestioned authority
to unilaterally force states
to reopen economies,
to suggesting he will
simply work with states
to allow them
to implement their own plans.
-What authority do you have?
-Well,
I have the ultimate authority.
The president
of the United States
has the authority to do
what the president has
the authority to do,
which is very powerful.
The president
of the United States
calls the shots.
I have the absolute right to do
if I want to.
When somebody's the president
of the United States,
the authority is total,
and that's the way
it's got to be.
-Your authority is total?
-Total. It's total.
-Again, I think part
of the problem here is,
Trump only knows
like three words,
which include absolute,
powerful, and total.
He used the word total
the way teenagers use
the word "random."
"My authority is like so total."
The president and his allies
ignored repeated warnings
that pandemic was coming,
and now in the face
of the evidence,
he's pushing to
prematurely reopen the economy
and repeat all the same mistakes
over again.
When the time
for an accounting comes,
we must remember that
this was not inevitable,
and that a long sequence
of failures led to this moment.
City harvest is New York City's
largest food rescue
organization,
and now they're working hard
to support local families
who are out of work due
to COVID-19 pandemic.
If you're watching this online,
please hit the donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
we love you.